thousands of older clark county school
district students finished their second
day of hybrid learning
eight news now reporter kristen drummond
joins us live in the newsroom with how
it's going so far and how many are
coming back this week kristin
christian some students in grades 6 9
and 12 came back in school buildings
yesterday and today
the first of two in-person cohorts the
other group returns thursday and friday
but
a majority of children are continuing
full-time distance education
the district says roughly 45 000 chose
to continue virtual learning for
various reasons including safety and
scheduling now
roughly 27 000 middle and high school
students
are attending class on campuses this
week after more than a year of distance
education i visited las vegas academy
today in downtown las vegas
students tell me class sizes are small
between three
and only 12 students educators are also
teaching those online and
in person simultaneously a few seniors
say there's a noticeable difference but
welcome this opportunity it's absolutely
wonderful honestly i
didn't know how much i needed this i'm
sitting at a desk now instead of at my
house
because you have to join the google me
you basically are doing your class and
your teacher happens to be in the same
room
this is the second wave of the
district's three-step reopening plan
rolling out in march and april
pre-kindergarten to third grade students
came back on march
1st the last grade levels returning to
buildings
will be april 6 after spring break
hybrid learning for secondary students
has block period schedules
students only attend their morning
classes in person and then
finish the school day remotely before
the start of after school
activities coming up at six why that's
creating a problem for some
students at las vegas academy who are
now visiting nearby businesses
to access wi-fi for their later courses
reporting live in the newsroom kristin
drummond
8 news now all right thank you kristen
our hot